hey you guys time for another movie your
retrospective this time going back to
1990 it was a lot better than I
remembered it yeah it's funny because
you had not seen it since it came came
out yeah um I actually saw it in the
theater in 1909 and saw it many times on
cable subsequent please yeah I
remembered it pretty well but maybe was
1990 yeah okay then I didn't see it in
the theater was in Korea yeah I saw it
afterwards I must have rented it yeah at
a video store after but it was I was in
the Army when I saw it I remember yeah I
distinctly remember so I must have
rented it yeah but yeah it came out in
1990 and directed by Joel Schumacher who
up to that point I mean I think he got
kind of a bad rap well deservedly so I
suppose bad rap later on because he did
[ __ ] Batman and Robin and all those
kind of shitty movies but before that
and before this one he'd actually done
saying almost fire do you remember the
money's came out in no cuz I was wrong I
did see in the theater no I saw this in
the theater at Camp Greaves Oh in Korea
yeah yeah I think that's where I saw
this because I remember seeing this on
the big screen and I forgot we were
seeing movies as they were coming out
yeah when we were up on the DMZ because
we kind of had priority and I spend a
dollar to see it but yeah yeah it's good
man I didn't mean to interrupt you I was
just trying to remember where it was and
I saw this yeah I distinctly remember
saying yeah cuz I remember seeing it in
the theater cuz I remit I mean 1990 that
was the year I graduated high school and
me and my friends went to the movies all
the time yeah I mean so and a lot of
good movies came out 1990 this one
Jacob's Ladder like some other one so we
saw does I remember liking it at the
time yeah blow it I kind of forgot about
it yeah yeah now and then revisiting it
again this is a gem man this movie was
much better than I remembered it and
this movie kind of stands up today it's
beautifully shot it does look really
yeah the way it's lit and the the sets
they weren't really sets they were they
look like it was being be it was shot at
a university somewhere
it was Loyola Biola yeah that's right
loyal in various museums around the way
it's all lit you know look really cool
yeah it's very gothic very gothic
looking well like I said you know Joel
Schumacher previous to Flatliners had
done saying I was fire he did the Lost
Boys in 1907
so the funny thing about this when we're
watching the movie because this is like
all-star cast man Julia Roberts is in
this Kiefer Sutherland yeah this cutting
the [ __ ] out of this she was making is
that one of the [ __ ] the Baldwin's
yeah ball was a lesser boom yeah he was
falling into there you know they're all
it's just it was the damn Hollywood Rat
Pack for that time and the weird thing
about it is that this was Julia Roberts
first movie after pretty woman and the
weird thing is I remembered pretty women
coming out like a long time before this
movie but it wasn't it was the same year
yeah this was her first movie after
pretty woman so she was like a big star
like on the road you know it's funny the
acting was good
yeah the acting was good I forgot how I
forgot that quality quality was very
high in the nineties but we didn't we
took it for granted
yeah a lot of [ __ ] you see today you not
a minute well I don't want to bag on
yeah I'm bag on movie today a lot of
movies today you know they look great
but the acting is or the script isn't
very good you know just a pants depends
on what you're watching but the quality
was really good yeah yeah well this
movie here okay
now if you have not seen Flatliners
they've remade it in 2017 I haven't seen
the remake I watched some reviews of
initially on yeah most people Ellen Page
is in it and I love her but most of the
reviews said you know there was really
no point in remaking it it didn't say
anything new and most of the reviews
just said it's not terrible it's just
very bland and very why the hell would
you want to remake this movie this
movie's [ __ ] beautiful yeah got a
minute leave this one alone
yeah and it's weird because I mean it
was a big hit at the time and it I guess
it has something of a cult following but
it's not it's not the type of movie that
everyone would be clamoring to remakes
it just seems like a strange thing to
remake and
then not really do anything new with it
or not you know what I mean I don't know
it's a group of these young grad
students their medical student medical
students yeah I think they're graduates
already though I think aren't they
didn't yet already graduated well I
think they're in their residency yes
they're messing around with near-death
experiences they're kind of inducing
death in each other to have this
near-death experience I had one of those
yeah yeah no I don't know if you were
normal listeners but regulars know that
I had a near-death experience and an
out-of-body experience real close
together you know about a week or so
apart and so and some of that some of
the stuffs that they say that describes
a near-death experiences yeah it's
what's like it's kind of a universal
kind of reports of you know feeling you
know super Pleasant and still and kind
of overjoyed and going to a place where
there's people and the tunnel in a way
yeah it's not all exactly like that and
then you know kind of experience in
another universe or another form of
reality nnessee doesn't seem like a
normal hallucination you know I know
what a hallucination is you know we
dropped our acid you know there's not a
normal hallucination it's much more real
than a hallucination someone's more real
than reality yeah it's almost like a
hyper reality and but anyway they're
inducing this death state in each other
and experiencing it for themselves and
they find out there's like a weird side
effect yeah it's basically okay it's the
interesting thing about it's all Kiefer
Sutherland's idea um he's kind of like
the you know the main guy behind it and
he wants to do it basically for fame
reasons he's like super cocky type of
thing and he's like you know I want to
be the one to prove that there's life
after death so he kind of ropes his four
friends I don't even know if they were I
think the implication was that they
weren't really friends before that
except maybe him in Kevin Bacon were but
um but he just knew them
these these were like the best students
they were the ones that he would trust
the most
like with bringing him back because
initially he wanted to be the one to
come back he's like I want to die for a
minute and then you bring me back and
I'll tell you what I saw yeah and then
you know so and they all all the other
ones when they end up doing they all
have their own reasons for doing it like
Kevin Bacon is an atheist he doesn't
think there's anything to it
so he almost kind of wants to do it like
to prove Kiefer Sutherland wrong Julia
Roberts is kind of like she works with
you know dying elderly people and she
had like a tragedy from her youth so she
wants to make sure that people that she
loved that have died are going to a good
place
yeah um you know so they all kind of had
their own reasons for going along with
it even though like I said Kiefer
Sutherland it's his idea and he stalks
them all into doing it now as it goes on
keep her Sutherland just the first to go
yeah and he has a sort of pleasant
experience at first but then it starts
getting weird
yeah they haven't some people have like
a hellish experience yeah if they've
done evil in their lives as unresolved
yeah so and then they come back into
this world they kind of bring it with
them yeah it's kind of a paranormal
effect yes it's pretty wild but I forgot
I forgot that aspect this movie yeah
yeah and the thing about it is that
Kiefer Sutherland he okay we're gonna
spoil it so I'm just yeah that's well
yeah yeah he's um when he was a kid I
haven't seen the movie go see it yeah
some services allowed to see it the
shutters got it right now right
it's was it I think it's a Netflix act
yeah I haven't seen it go watch it then
come back but yeah so keep her
Sutherland he was he's under for a
minute they bring him back was it a
minute or might if it might have gone a
little bit longer cuz he was hard well
they were all bent you know they were
all taken bets and everything well yeah
but the thing about it is that Kiefer
Sutherland comes back and his whole
thing was that when he was a kid he was
kind of a bully and he had bullied this
kid named Billy Mahoney him and his
little bully friends had like chased
this kid up a tree and then we're
throwing rocks at him and the kid fell
out of the tree and died he died yes so
um so Kiefer Sutherland was like
responsible for this kids death more
so Billy Mahoney kind of comes back even
though I don't think he came back as
like a revenant I think that was Kiefer
Sutherland's own conscience yes he
backing himself he was attack yeah yeah
because it wasn't yeah one point Kevin
Bacon like finds him in the truck and
he's like has a pickaxe at himself even
though he saw it the kid it's not really
the kid yeah the kid is not there it's
yes you're attacking yourself for your
own sins in the image of the thing that
you did wrong
yes back comes back to you now what
Kiefer Sutherland now see so he starts
having all the soup with this apparently
this little kid like beating the [ __ ]
out of him all the time but he doesn't
tell the other ones that he just tells
him oh I you know I know there was
something there and we should go further
and stuff so then all the other ones
start like auctioning off we'll all go
for two minutes we'll all go for three
minutes obviously you know what I mean
and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] happens and
then there's like this kind of love
triangle thing going on between Kiefer
Sutherland and Kevin Bacon and Julia
Roberts where you know bacon they had
this thing going on Kevin Bacon is
trying to like outbid her because he
doesn't want her to go because he's
worried that she's gonna die
so that so that there's that whole
competition and there's like whole
competition between so there's that
whole thing going on but as as they all
go Oliver Platt who was kind of there
there's the comic relief he's the only
one that doesn't go cuz he just thinks
the whole thing is a stupid idea and
he's probably right but but the four
other ones actually do end up going and
they all bring something back with them
and it's always something bad now the
thing that some criticisms I've seen of
this movie are that you know yes every
time they bring somebody back you know
that it's longer and longer and it's
yeah I've seen people complain that it's
like oh it's repetitive because every
time they have to bring the person back
and they're like doing them with the
paddles and all this other kind of stuff
and they show that over and over again
um you know but that's just the nature
of this movie in nature this movie it
didn't bother me also the movies of the
time did that it was it was a movie of
its era yeah you know nowadays they pair
everything down you know what I mean to
something small they try to pack a lot
in a movie down yes you know although
remake was even more
was it like they just did the same thing
over and over again and something else
too and I think this bothered me more at
the time but when I rewatched it didn't
bother me as much that the people's
quote-unquote sins that they brought
back with them two of them had to do
with childhood bullying one Julia
Roberts's was she felt responsible for
her dad's suicide even if she wasn't
because she was just a little kid he was
in joy attic she but she had felt guilty
about her whole life so her thing that
she had to resolve was that she had to
forgive herself actually and like get
rid of her guilt and whatnot but really
the Baldwin character he's the only one
who's trauma is ongoing because he feels
bad because he goes and bangs every
woman that meds right I forgot a bit and
video tasted without them knowing right
he's got a whole collection of and he's
got like a whole collection of it so
obviously he feels like a [ __ ] about and
oh and he's engaged too so he's also
cheating on his fiancee on top of
everything whether or deihi just have
videotapes of the past no he was still
he was still doing it he was still doing
okay like that because they kept showing
him like hitting on women like all the
time so he basically all all he had to
do he didn't really have to do anything
to resolve it like his girlfriend or his
fiancee came and found out she was like
[ __ ] off Joe and then you know what I
mean and then she left and then he
didn't have any anymore cuz I guess that
was how that was resolved but at the
time I think it bothered me cuz it's
like really is this the whole like
that's the whole sins and stuff but now
that I see it I'm like you know what I
think that's better because everybody's
you know most people aren't serial
killers most people aren't Tara knows
mundane sense yeah most people just have
these little Monday oh I bullied
somebody as a kid and I feel bad about
it you know oh I cheated on somebody and
I feel bad but it's it's usually just
mundane [ __ ] like that so you're not
gonna get like in a group of five random
people everybody has regrets and they
have regrets of different magnitude or
serial killers yeah read a lot bigger
[ __ ] yeah and I always feel like
probably serial killers don't regret it
I have regrets
[Laughter]
so they would just die and be like a
supplies there right seeing this movie
again no MIT makes you want to I want to
get this on blu-ray for a collection
this movie's beautiful it really the way
it looks
the clothes this the settings where it's
shot just little things like Bacon's
truck get out like this look like some
kind of old foreign army truck I don't
know what it's yeah there's like mash
yeah it was just just a lot of stuff
that we used to see in the late 80s and
the early yes era is represented in the
movie and it looked cool it was like an
idealized version yeah 1990 and here's
the thing like if you think about it too
hard it doesn't really make sense it's
like you know why would these medals why
are they there's like museum why is it
all dark and light it's just for
ambience and stuff like that you know
and how are they getting all this
equipment without anybody know why are
they in this marble thing doing this I
think there was some symbolism about
going to head well yeah religious
symbolism to it you know they're trying
to evoke that and then yeah true you
know I tried to I tried to explain
myself earlier that today they edit
things down so they can make a two hour
movie be more like four or five episodes
from a miniseries it's covering a lot of
ground they didn't do that in the 90s
this movie today you could do it but
about a in a 45-minute single episode
out of a yeah the TV series it didn't
need to be as long as it did but in back
in those days that's just how we did it
things were kind of expanded out yeah
and fleshed out into a movie that was
more visual you know yeah that good had
a good ambience to it I liked it I did
to you in like a younger person might be
frustrated by they might think it's slow
and plodding I don't know but I never
got sick really slow and plodding but
like I said you know this we came from
this area I was 18 when this came out so
this is how I expect a story to be told
to me in a certain way and you know and
like I was gonna say to that you know
that I like the idea
like the premise behind the movie is
like so like a group of medical students
you know inducing death so they could I
mean if you think about it too hard yes
there's still no empirical evidence it's
still their word they came back and
they're subjectively telling you there's
no proof there's no way to prove it so
although there was some paranoid
phenomena remember that the boy that the
boy that he thought he killed but fell
out of the tree was yeah don't rocks in
it and it was actually making wounds on
his head yeah but he was doing that to
himself to himself okay I they didn't
specifically lay that out but like I
said there was one scene where Kevin
Bacon has gone to the the girl who he
used to bully when he was a kid and he
went to go she was still alive and he
went to ask forgiveness for her so his
visions would go away and he took Keeper
7 long with him and Keith Kiefer stayed
in the truck and the kid quote/unquote
attacked him well he was the truck like
with a pickaxe or something but then
when Kevin Bacon came back oh he was
doing it to himself so so the
implication being that he had been
beating the [ __ ] out of himself for a
whole entire time while perceiving it
yeah that he had brought this kid back
from the dead somehow yeah you know what
I mean so like I said it's one of those
ones where you know don't think about it
too hard it's gonna ruin the move it's a
you know it's a cool premise it's like
you get to see you know medical students
and and the very you know the very
famous very good-looking people at the
time it's like you know kind of still in
the Brat Pack era a little bit you know
you get to see them like bringing other
people back from the dead and having
hallucinations and all this other stuff
and like you said the cinematography on
this and even though like I said it
doesn't really make any sense for a
minute from an experimental standpoint
you know want to turn some damn lights
on but it looks super cool they're like
in this with all these [ __ ] religious
murals there's like all these um like it
was really like in this alleyway like
where they go after one of this like all
these like neon like graffiti paintings
yeah like it's almost like jollily
it's cool yeah it's like a java move it
is lights up on things yeah it's really
cool-looking I smoked a steam coming out
of the manhole covers yeah it's not
really the right season for that it
doesn't matter that's what I mean just
doesn't matter
I don't think watching the mood
like watching a music video yeah kind of
there was a lot of movies this guy I
don't know if this movie did it but
there were a lot of movies in that era
that kind of had that same look like
seven deadly sins and butterfly effect
kind of looked like this a little bit in
a way I remember him being kind of like
this but I haven't seen those in a while
yeah seven but but yeah like and this
kind of look went for a long time I mean
yeah even that damn
terrible Arnold Schwarzenegger movie had
that look - what was that [ __ ] called
about the devil we was fighting the
devil and the end of days that was 1999
terrible movie that was many although
visually it looked it looked good in
parts I always associate flak Flatliners
with Jacob's Ladder
because yeah Jacob's Ladder because I
think they came out I mean they came out
the same year I probably saw them I
think they only came out with a couple
within a couple months of each other and
I saw them both in the theater and they
both had a very specific look kind of
feel look to them and you know Jacob's
Ladder was obviously about someone
having like a near-death experience also
even though you didn't know that till
the end spoiler alert but um you know
what I mean but so it was the same kind
of thing where there was like this
melding of like reality and an vision I
guess that had kind of I think Jacob
slaughter was a little bit more of a
freak out I don't know if the goth scene
influenced these movies are these movies
influenced the goth scene but these had
a very gothic look really yeah a slick
look to them and the dark lighting of
flames flickering and yeah cherubs and
[ __ ] well like I said I it's hard to say
because I mean The Lost Boys which was
also Joel Schumacher film had come out
three years before this one and when
that came out you know some of the day I
guess the vampires were kind of more
punk or metal looking than God yeah but
Goths were super into that movie but I
knew some people that looked like that
before that movie came out you know what
I mean it's it's funny because yes we've
been in the goth scene so long it's like
whenever a movie came out like with a
goth character like Beetlejuice for
example for a little while like you get
like people copy and now well no
you get like normals like saying hey
Lydia yeah yeah I'm like [ __ ] I've
looked like this since 1982 there were
also some movies that I remember they
just ripped me off the crow you saw
everybody crow a lot of stuff but
remember the prophecy yeah
I remember seeing that film kind of
influencing certain things inside the
godsey's weird yeah you know and I
remember like it's a beauty because like
after the matrix came out oh yeah yeah
every time I walked anywhere matrix I
got a [ __ ] jackets that look like
that I'm like okay we've only had these
like many years yeah thanks a lot
matrix is x in the films though I have
to get those I liked the first one
I don't remember the other two although
I remember seeing the matrix and being
like I was like that's not as edgy as it
think it is yeah all right but I'm kind
of an [ __ ] like that I probably need
to see them again but yeah I'd have to
see them again cuz I haven't seen them
for a very long time so you know but it
was kind of cool to revisit Flatliners
like I said I saw it in the theater I
saw it on cable like a lot of time
subsequently so I hadn't really
forgotten much of it um but you had kind
of forgotten it so it was kind of good
to like revisit it because she said I
didn't remember it looking like that it
still does look it looks very much like
the Lost Boys looked where everything
was like fire it's a pretty move now
yeah it's a good looking movie like I
said even though the aesthetics of it
don't really make any sense from like a
logical standpoint that shouldn't really
be nowadays art you know and watching it
for me you know I'm just saying for me
it was kind of like a time time capsule
and like a trip back to the 90s where
things were just done for beauty
yeah movies you know things were just
lit a certain way it was a commis comic
book like yeah you know I liked it and I
don't have any problem with that like if
they want to do a particular style yeah
you know movie had a style yeah and like
I said this was kind of like this was
probably like Joel Schumacher's
last
before he started getting [ __ ] on for
doing like Batman or Robin do you know
what you know what the style kind of
reminds me of was that the Dead Ringers
style yeah the way the way things were
shot in those buildings you know I mean
the really good-looking that was Canada
that was shot in Canada wouldn't it
pretty much everything is nowadays but
it kind of had that style stylistic cone
to it to me although it was I would say
the strength of the style was the same
it was a different style it was more of
a Catholic looking yeah but it now
remind me because we just watched this
the other day but I don't remember if
this was an aspect of the original movie
or not now when they came back from
being dead
yeah they had like all this of like
hauntings and they were seeing [ __ ] and
everything like that but they didn't get
like any special abilities or anything
did they and not only even think did
they even mention anything like that
because that was an aspect of the remake
where they had all the sins stuff like
in the original one but they also had
like a little special bit like one of
them could like play the piano suddenly
you know do everybody you banned [ __ ]
like that so I but I don't think I don't
even think they mentioned any of that
and I think pretty much it was wrong
about everything was play there
everything kind of had plausible
deniability yeah could have just been
then yeah but I mean I think the whole
thing the whole point of the original
one I think was you know it was kind of
like a metaphor about sin and about
expiating your sins yeah you know what I
mean come to terms with the evil that
you had done right and even if it wasn't
evil like I said it was just mundane
[ __ ] mostly but that's what most people
would have in their life sitting in
front of the wrong person and making fun
of people and Julia yeah and then you
know or learning to forgive yourself
you know first stuff that wasn't your
fault like when you're not I think
everybody had one yeah they had to
resolve when they came back yeah they
did and like it was just four of them
because like I said there were five main
characters but the one guy played by
Oliver Platt yeah he didn't go because
he was just like he wasn't gonna have it
it's a good old flick it looks good I
recommend you guys go check it out yeah
and like I said if any of you seen the
remake let me know because I've heard
that it really really was
and they had it they were shown it was
either on Netflix or shudder it's on
there now I'm pretty sure it was Netflix
it was my right yeah cuz it it's funny
because we've been noticing that Netflix
I guess maybe for competition from other
streaming services has actually been
adding more older movies yeah they're
trying they still have all their new
stuff but yeah they've added like a [ __ ]
ton of like older horror movies unlike
classics and stuff like that in the last
few weeks so I think they're definitely
trying to like up their game in that
department which hey that's fine cuz we
have both Netflix and shudder yeah and
if I can just witch back and forth and
see most of this [ __ ] I want to see tell
you what Matt shutters the best five
dollars a month he spent they added oh
did you better pay us
they added a whole bunch of new stuff
yeah the other day that we're definitely
gonna get around to reviewing I won't
spoil the surprise
but they added a whole [ __ ] ton of stuff
that we're gonna do so mostly from yeah
all right rapido that will do it for our
review of the 1990 cult u locker film
Flatliners check it out if you haven't
seen it and remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the side
part sidebar that goes to a PayPal
account if you'd like to give a one-time
donation remember these here movie
retrospectives come out every Friday our
13 o'clock matinee three movies also
follow us on [ __ ] you yeah comes out
every Sunday and our regular episodes
come out every Tuesday so check them out
we will see you next time bye